c'est sous ce quinquennat que la france
est devenue importatrice nette de
produits alimentaires vis-à-vis de ses
voisins européens
pour la première fois depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale alors moi je vous le dis
avec moi présidente il n'y aura pas de
décroissance agricole je mettrai fin à
ce projet européen qui a été adopté par
la majorité présidentielle
farm to fork de la ferme à la fourchette
et qui organise la décroissance de la
production européenne je pense que c'est
une pure folie à l'heure du
réchauffement climatique à l'heure où on
risque d'avoir des familles n'a lors de
la guerre en ukraine nous avons besoin
d'une agriculture productive et je veux
que ce thème de ce terme de la
production revienne au centre des
priorités de la nation dans ma vision de
l'agriculture française c'est une
agriculture forte entreprenante
innovante et qui reste fidèle à notre
modèle familial alors pour cela et bien
il faut que nos agriculteurs puissent
vivre dignement de leur métier et moi
j'ai quatre priorités la première des
prix justes et rémunérateurs
avec des revenus aussi supplémentaires
et de la valeur ajoutée sur les
exploitations le deuxième c'est la
libération des énergies moins de charges
moins de normes la troisième c'est la
modernisation par l'investissement dans
l'outil de production dans les filières
et aussi dans la recherche et la
quatrième c'est le renouvellement des
générations dynamique parce que le défi
humain est immense